[Musique]
bonsoir 1 19 mars très heureux de vous
retrouver pour une nouvelle semaine
d'information locale sur tv 78 2 voici
les titres de ce journal la barre des 20
cas de coronavirus a été franchie dans
les yvelines parmi eux celui d'une
enseignante de l'école des sablons à
poissy qui a contraint les autorités à
fermer l'établissement pendant 14 jours
dans cette édition nous verrons
également comment les pharmaciens font
face à l'épidémie
le colis de 19 a largement perturbé la
tenue du paris-nice 2020 cette équipe
ont renoncé à participer à la course
cycliste au départ des yvelines des
restrictions aussi pour approcher les
coureurs ambiance sur les lignes de
départ à plaisir et chevreuse et puis la
dernière ligne droite avant les
élections municipales premier tour ce
dimanche l'actualité de la campagne avec
ce soir la présentation des candidats
attraper la réunion chez l'habitant
donné par catherine perrotin refasse
taillez-les en cours et puis à la fin de
ce journal direction au plaisir pour
assister à une leçon de littérature
[Musique]
elle la décision a été prise hier au
terme d'une réunion exceptionnelle
auquel ont participé le préfet des
yvelines le maire de poissy l' agence
régionale de santé et l'éducation
nationale l'école élémentaire des à
sablons à poissy est fermée pour 14
jours jusqu'au 22 mars une enseignante
de l'établissement qui compte quinze
classes et 398 élèves a été testé
positif aux coronavirus positivo
coronavirus son état de santé n'est pas
inquiétant elle est confinée à son
domicile pendant 14 jours la rs enquête
actuellement pour connaître les
personnes qui auraient pu être en
contact avec l'institutrice la fermeture
de l'école décision est nécessaire aux
sablons ou la continuité pédagogique
sera tout de même annoncé écoutez assuré
pardon écoutez à ce propos le directeur
académique des yvelines
comme cette enseignante de ce1 à celle
des cours de chorales à d'autres enfants
de l'école en fait la décision a été
prise de ne pas faire mais simplement la
classe mais toute l'école et donc on est
en train d'organiser deux parapets la
continuité pédagogique
voyez les enseignants parents qui vont
devoir préparer des exercices
d'entraînement pour les élèves et
dessins pour un ou deux jours et des
femmes ils vont être informés que ces
exercices d'entraînement
elles sont à consulter sur un blog etc
en cliquant sur ce blog la classe de ce1
par exemple si mon enfant et on sait là
et bien j'ai accès aux exercices que la
maîtresse ou le mettre à préparer pour
les deux jours à venir
voilà on est en train de tout organiser
pour que les enfants perdent pas leur
temps et puis ceux de schiste de
travailler quoi on a inventé ce matin
les modalités
même si l'on s'y prépare depuis quinze
jours mais en tout cas d'une chose très
pratico pratique coin mais nouveaux cas
donc de kovy 19 dans les yvelines
rappelons que le premier avait été
décelée à versailles mercredi dernier
est d'après les informations de nos
confrères du parisien vingt-et-une
personnes seraient contaminées
aujourd'hui dans les yvelines
le département n'est pas pour autant un
foyer épidémiologique les cas étant
disséminés sur tout le territoire est
deux centres de diagnostic sont en tout
cas installés ils sont en place le
centre hospitalier de versailles et
celui de mantes la jolie
quatre cas par exemple on était
détectée à la maison de retraite du
coeur volant à louveciennes
établissement a donc été confinés depuis
ce dimanche 15h l'origine de la
contamination viendrait d'un personnel
soignant de remplacement aucun des
résidents n'a été hospitalisé leur état
de santé n'est pas inquiétant pour le
moment je reçois sur ce plateau renault
nadjani bonsoir en soit vous êtes
pharmacien à rambouillet président de
l'uar ps pharmacienne de france c'est
l'une l'union régionale des
professionnels de santé
comment avec vos confrères vous vous
vivez cette période un peu particulière
à écouter je crois que l'ensemble des
professionnels de santé sont sous
tension
parce que les demandes sont importantes
parce que l'inquiétude est là ceci étant
dit il faut toujours raison garder et ne
pas oublier que la grippe saisonnière
fait en france entre 8000 et 15 millions
par an selon les années donc pour
l'instant on est dans ce cadre là et que
bien sûr il faut être respectueux d'un
certain nombre de mesures barrières
comme ça a été déjà annoncée à plusieurs
reprises et relayée sur toutes les
chaînes d'info eh bien on est sollicité
ça on est sollicité voudrais que vous
observez depuis quelques jours dans les
pharmacies le centre 15 subit depuis pas
mal de temps cette cette approche là il
y a le numéro national aussi et puis
effectivement l'ensemble des pharmacies
nous sommes sollicités notamment pour le
gel hydroalcoolique et qui est
aujourd'hui pour l'instant en rupture
aujourd'hui on est vraiment en rupture
de stock de ce gel hydroalcoolique et il
est en rupture donc la quasi totalité
des pharmacies et et j'attire quand même
l'attention de feu sur le fait qu'il
faut vraiment prendre des produits
qu'ils soient fabriqués avec toute la
sécurité nécessaire autour d'un produit
qui est un produit d'hygiène certes mais
s'il n'est pas bien fabriqué il n'est
pas forcément ni efficace et encore plus
s'il peut entraîner peut-être quelques
réactions non souhaitée et d'ailleurs
pour contrer l'action de quelques joints
peu scrupuleux le gouvernement a
plafonné à fixer un prix de 2 euros 1
pour ces gels hydro-alcooliques
pour 50 millilitres 2 euros pour ces
jeunes d'ailleurs le gouvernement vous a
autorisé depuis quelques jours fabriquer
vous même ces gels hydroalcooliques afin
d'autoriser les pharmaciens pardon
qu'est ce que vous pensez de cette
décision est ce que c'était une bonne
décision à prendre mais à écouter
l'ensemble des pharmacies sont en
capacité de faire un certain nombre de
préparation c'est vrai que avec
l'industrie maintenant c'est de moins en
moins le cas mais on a été formé pour ça
ça fait partie de notre père mais qui
est notre spécificité et je crois que
c'est une très bonne
comment dire solution ou décision du
gars qui a été prise parce qu'on est
parfaitement en capacité de fabriquer
non pas le gène parce que il faut mettre
un gélifiant dedans mais en tout cas un
soluté hydroalcoolique avec les mêmes
propriétés aussi bien contre lui russe
que les bactéries pour avoir cette
hygiène nécessaire et faire barrière à
la progression du virus
ça vous le dit tous les pharmaciens a
priori sont en capacité de pouvoir le
faire tous les pharmaciens sont a priori
en capacité de le faire sous réserve
qu'ils aient bien le préparatoire qui
soit toujours en fonction et s'ils le
souhaitent
ce n'est pas une obligation on a parlé
des gels hydroalcooliques y aussi les
masques qui sont prises et les
pharmaciens les les vendre mais alors
sont seulement pour les professionnels
de santé les malades que ceux vendus ces
masques alors bien une rupture
effectivement pour les masques enfin des
différentes formes des masques et que
l'on a reçu une dotation spécifiquement
pour les professionnels de santé parce
qu'il est évident qu'il faut protéger
les professionnels de santé dans leur
ensemble afin de combattre cette
évolution de cette épidémie et que dans
un certain nombre de cas sur
prescription médicale et à condition que
ce soit nécessaire pour la personne
c'est à dire quelqu'un qui a diminué
clim et ou qui est sous traitement
notamment de chimiothérapie etc
on peut dépanner dans un premier temps
parce que notre dotation a été seulement
de quelques bouts
donc ça va très très vite dernière
question en 20 secondes
à votre avis le rôle du pharmacien dans
ce genre d'épisodes qui aussi peuvent à
venir ce genre d'épisode à quelques
psychos quel est le rôle du pharmacien
d'abord le rôle de pharmaciens ces deux
d'essayer de calmer le jeu de remettre
les choses à leur juste niveau bien sûr
il faut encore une fois être prudent et
le pharmacien fait cette ce conseil est
cet accompagnement tout au long de
l'année
tout le temps là on met en lumière
effectivement parce qu'ils passent que
c'est sous tension mais c'est notre
métier que d'accompagner dans ce cadre
là mais aussi dans la traumatologie et
un certain nombre de pathologies que le
pharmacien désengorge notamment les
services de soins et je crois qu'il est
important de d'identifier de souligner
cette action qui devrait être comment
dire encore plus mis en avant
eh bien merci renaud naji d'être venu en
parler si un plateau je rappelle que
vous êtes pharmacien à rambouillet
président de l'uer rhdp est ce
pharmacien ile de france on a parlé d
east barrière je vous invite à vous
rendre sur le site du ministère de la
santé 1 pour connaître tous ces gestes
barrière est la célèbre course cycliste
paris-nice est bien partie des yvelines
malgré le contexte sanitaire mais
toutefois avec quelques prévention
mesures de prévention à lio coronavirus
les conférences de presse ont par
exemple été annulée les poignées de
mains interdite et le speaker plus
concis que d'habitude manon varaldo pour
ce sujet la course paris-nice est parti
pour sa 11e édition depuis les yvelines
mais cette année les spectateurs ne
pouvait pas s'approcher des bus et des
coureurs pour cause de concilier liés à
l'épidémie de coronavirus c'était
décevant - j'ai posé la question si
l'événement allait être maintenue parce
que vu qu'il y a
le corps d'un virus et c'est vraiment
une tragédie pour les événements
sportifs en général de ce que je vois je
pense qu'il n'y a pas beaucoup de monde
parce que l'événement fait que les gens
ont peu peur le public était moins
nombreux cette année mais les vedettes
de la célèbre course n'ont pas manqué le
rendez vous
[Musique]
les coureurs sont montés sur le podium
mais le speaker avaient pour consigne de
ne pas les interroger
thomas voeckler ancien cycliste a remis
aux jeunes pédaleurs yvelinois un casque
julian alain philippe a reçu le prix du
fair play il avait donné lors du tour de
france son maillot jaune à un enfant sur
le bord de la route qui avait froid
les cyclistes eux ont dû braver la pluie
à 11h top départ pour les coureurs du
paris nice hier dimanche ils se sont
élancés depuis plaisir ce jeune de 11
ans a lui aussi tout donné dvd vous pour
faire un souci salon les jambes
malgré la pluie le public s'est essayé
aux animations autour du vélo proposé
dans le village du paris nice on a le
freestyle airbag qu'un gros coussins
géants où c'est une vraie table
structure d'initiation et d'entraînement
puisqu'il ya des éducateurs qui sont
présents aussi pour là aussi le deuxième
parc donc est vraiment un parcours de
dressing pour les pour les enfants c'est
parti j'ai fait la course en vélo
après j'ai fait un simulateur de pente
en vélo les free state sont juste là bas
bah c'est qu'on les voit faire des
détours des saltos c'est super autre
animation ce jeune homme de 16 ans
pratique le trial depuis quatre ans dans
un club à epône il enchaîne figure et
obstacles sous les yeux des spectateurs
est faux le franchir avec la plus belle
et une meilleure technique pour pouvoir
aller plus en plus heureux ça demande
pas mal d'entraînement et faut le faire
sérieusement l'entraînement ford et du
sérieux il y en avait avec le
coronavirus les précautions étaient de
mise est des gants pour toucher les
guidons des vélos du village
d'animations c'était très sportif on s'y
attendait pas mais effectivement c'était
assez sportif où j'ai dû me battre
contre le vélo blanc qui essayait de me
rattraper
mais c'était très sympa c'est un très
beau
evènement quand plaisir surtout et pour
anomalie
roland polydor avec le corona blé russe
cette équipe ont décliné leur
participation à cette course mais
l'organisation a ouvert les inscriptions
à d'autres groupes
une première étape à plaisir remporté
par maximilian sharman et puis après
plaisir la deuxième étape du paris nice
prenait le départ ce matin de chevreuse
michael et demi d'euros et nicolas
landry était sur place
après une très belle première étape à
plaisir aujourd'hui à le départ sera
donné depuis un chevreuil une petite
commune de moins de 6000 habitants
direction le loiret pour une étape de
166 km
je suis avec madame le maire de
chevreuse madame le maire j'imagine que
vous êtes ravi d'accueillir ce
paris-nice ici assez fabuleux pour une
commune comme la nôtre c'est vraiment un
honneur et puis c'est vraiment un moment
génial à partager avec tous les
bénévoles tous ceux qui sont motivés
pour cette organisation on est vraiment
ravis et fiers d'accueillir le paris
nice où et quand ça se prépare justement
pas réunies dans une ville alors c'est
un petit peu compliqué parce que voyez
notre commune c'est une rue principale
et si elle est complètement bloquée donc
pas mal d'organisation en amont les
écoles les transports etc
le stationnement mais tout ça c'est
vraiment anticiper les le travail a été
fait depuis le mois de décembre
maintenant et je pense qu'on est à peu
près près et et voilà tout va bien se
passer on est on est vraiment ravi je re
c'est une petite commune de moins de
6000 habitants qui va être connus au
niveau mondial maintenant alors j'espère
qu'elle l'était déjà on a plein d'atouts
qui font qu'on devait déjà être connue
donc j'espère que ce sera juste une
confirmation qu à chevreuse ont fait de
belles choses et qu'on est ravi
d'accueillir du public pour des
événements comme ça comme pour d'autres
est la suite à voir dans l'émission 7 8
sport c'est à retrouver après ce journal
sûreté des 78 et en raison du
coronavirus on a appris aujourd'hui
l'annulation d'un autre événement le 13e
eco trail de paris qui devait prendre le
départ samedi
depuis l'île de loisirs de saint quentin
en yvelines un autre événement le
mondial du golf prévue la semaine
prochaine à mantes la jolie est
également annulée
[Musique]
nj - 6 j - 6 avant le premier tour des
élections municipales ce dimanche dans
moins de quinze jours ils seront 2 159
fraîchement élu à revêtir l'écharpé
tricolore dans le département si le
maire est un personnage est bien connu
des habitants son relais c'est au son et
ses fonctions par dow le sont parfois
beaucoup moins alors à quoi sert un
maire et par indirectement également à
quoi sert une mairie tour d'horizon avec
nicolas kirillovitch c'est un poste
symbolique souvent convoités et
appréciée des habitants le maire d'une
commune est avant tout un agent de
l'état il est notamment responsable de
l'état civil c'est donc lui qui peut
vous marier c'est lui aussi qui prend
acte des naissances et des décès sur le
territoire communal en lien avec ses
missions historiques c'est madame ou
monsieur le maire qui est en charge du
recensement de la population
enfin le premier magistrat de la ville
doit organiser bien sûr l'ensemble des
élections durant les six années de son
mandat le maire en fait fait partie de
la vie locale c'est un administré est là
pour aider ses amis seraient donc les
communes vont s'occuper du quotidien des
yvelinois
c'est à dire par exemple les mariages
les naissances qui ne s'occupait des
écoles va s'occuper des espaces verts
tout ce qui concerne finalement la
commune de proximité plus technique le
rôle exécutif le maire prépare et
applique les décisions du conseil
municipal
il prend des arrêtés municipaux
représentent la commune en justice et
les charges et aussi des pouvoirs de
police pour assurer la sécurité et la
tranquillité publique
il peut s'appuyer sur la police
municipale évidemment pour réaliser
l'ensemble de ces tâches le maire peut
compter sur le travail d'agents et de
nombreux services
les mairies sont notamment responsables
de la gestion des écoles maternelles et
primaires
ils doivent donc organiser les activités
périscolaires le temps de restauration
ou encore le recrutement des atsem les
assistants territoriaux spécialisés des
écoles maternelles
autre compétence majeure d'une mairie
l'urbanisme et le logement et la mise au
point du fameux paix et lui le plan
local d'urbanisme ce document fixe les
règles à respecter pour les
constructions auteurs zones à préserver
ou encore objectifs sociaux
enfin une mairie doit s'occuper de la
construction et du fonctionnement des
équipements sportifs et culturels et
votent les subventions aux clubs et
associations
depuis quelques années les domaines
d'action des communes var et une partie
est transféré une collectivité qui voit
ses prérogatives augmenté
l'intercommunalité à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la communauté
d'agglomération est ainsi responsable
des espaces verts du réseau des
médiathèques des déchets de certaines
voiries ou encore de l'assainissement
des eaux pluviales et usées attrape ils
sont d'ailleurs cinq candidats se
présenter pour le poste de maire l'édile
sortant guy malandain l'adjoint ali
rabais le conseiller d'opposition othman
neuf trous et bakou keita et patrick
planque présentation trappe ville de 32
1714 habitants où cinq candidats se font
face pour les élections municipales
président de la pépinière d'entreprises
promo paul lotman nasro est candidat
pour la deuxième fois au scrutin dans la
ville après 2014
l'élu d'opposition également conseiller
régional fait équipe avec mustapha
larbaoui l'ancien président du club de
football local sa liste est soutenu par
la droite et le centre départemental
aujourd'hui on a construit un grand
rassemblement autour d'un projet est
alors que nous avons identifié les dix
priorités essentielles qui sont celles
des habitants qui sont celles que nous
défendons depuis 2014
il ya des choses utiles qui ont été
faites à trappes ces vingt dernières
années et ce qui n'a pas été fait en 20
ans ne le sera pas dans les prochaines
années par les mêmes personnes
il faut donc qu'on aille sur les sujets
qui n'ont pas encore été traités c'est
une première candidature pour lui aux
municipales à trappes
patrick planque était déjà en lice il ya
trois ans sur le territoire comme
candidat suppléant aux dernières
législatives
comme toutes les listes lutte ouvrière
il souhaite organiser la lutte des
travailleurs au niveau de la commune
c'est une ville ouvrière avec une longue
histoire
de lutte quand même et quand on parle
aujourd'hui de recréer un parti à parti
d'une travailleurs en parti ouvrier qui
organiserait les choses dans les
quartiers qui organiserait les choses
dans la ville et ben dans les plus
anciens il ya une petite étoile
il est le maire de trappes depuis 2001
guy malandain est en lice pour un
quatrième mandat dans la ville une
candidature divers gauche soutenu par la
république en marche le parti socialiste
et le parti radical de gauche
l'élu souhaite rester à la tête du
conseil municipal pour voir aboutir les
projets lancés comme l'enfouissement de
la nationale 10 il ya besoin de
continuer au plan humain social éducatif
urbanistique etc
il a besoin de continuer de poursuivre
la politique qui a été menée jusqu'ici
pour pour terminer alors terminé veut
pas dire qu'il faudra rien faire il ya
encore des choses qui me tiennent à
coeur
cette campagne son premier engagement
politique kate à bas coût et la tête de
liste de citoyens en actions candidature
portée avec son binôme youssef bouchikhi
est derrière eux un collectif
d'habitants qui souhaite que les
trappistes se réapproprient leur ville
en favorisant notamment la démocratie
locale
l avis des trappes est gérée par des
gens qui sont pas et se travaille déjà
et qui te connaissent pas nos problèmes
on a beaucoup de difficulté à trappes
niveau logement social jeunesse etc
les nouveaux maîtres le coin est
vraiment travailler l'amélioration de
tout ça quoi enfin l'adjoint au maire
ali rabe est également candidat face au
maire sortant sa liste est soutenu par
génération europe ecologie les verts et
le parti communiste
l'élu peut compter aussi sur l'appui de
benoît hamon côté éducation c'est le
retour à la semaine de quatre jours
qu'il souhaite pour la rentrée 2020 donc
on a organisé un référendum pendant
trois semaines nous sommes allés au
contact des habitants dans les marchés
chez l'habitant dans les gares dans les
écoles également et on a recueilli plus
de mille votants ce qui est vraiment
très impressionnant et qui montre que
les trappistes ont envie de donner leur
avis à près de 80% les trappistes ont
décidé de revenir à la semaine de quatre
jours
la dernière ligne droite de cette
campagne pour les élections notamment à
plaisir la liste à gauche tout mené par
djamel niati était sur le terrain hier
dimanche au centre commercial brigide
ce tribut sion de tracts échanges avec
les habitants pour cette candidature
soutenue par plusieurs mouvements de
gauche dont le pcf la france insoumise
ou encore génération au coeur du
programme l'écologie les valeurs
d'égalité et d'émancipation du citoyen
écoutez des jo mais n'y at-il lors de sa
venue sur notre plateau au début du mois
l'approché écologique c'est un
raisonnement global c'est quand on
construit quelque chose c'est en tenir
compte
c'est du début à la fin c'est à dire ccc
ccc dans le dans la proche c'est dans
l'assiette de nos enfants c'est dans la
circulation plaisir oise ce n'est pas
l'argent qui gouverne tout il ya de
l'humain autour de tous savez on pourra
continuer à faire en sorte que plaisir
s'étendre à tout va et que ce soit un
centre commercial encore plus grand
c'est quoi c'est de la pollution en
permanence c'est quoi comme emploi assez
de l'emploi précaire
oui vous me parler d'écologie l'écologie
s'est donné les moyens aux gens de vivre
et à moins d'une semaine du premier tour
des élections municipales les candidats
multiplient aussi les réunions à
elancourt et catherine perron tort fast
tête de liste de réinventons elancourt
organisé une réunion en petit comité ce
week-end aurélie rond et yves hub stand
bergès je voulais un peu plus libéré un
cadre assez atypique pour cette réunion
de campagne de la liste et réinventons
elancourt
objectif présenter les grandes lignes de
son programme en petit comité et ainsi
mieux répondre aux questions des
citoyens
il ya des idées que nous nous n'avions
pas eu et qui nous sont venues des
habitants comme par exemple dire que le
quotient familial est particulièrement
injuste et qu'il faut absolument le
rendre plus juste plus évolutif
voir par exemple ce qui s'est passé à la
clé de saint pierre avec le fait que le
dernier médecin de la clé saint pierre
va peut-être partir ça c'est arrivé en
cours de campagne
donc notre projet a été extrêmement
évolutif cette liste de gauche qui se
veut participative propose un projet
alternatif en trois axes majeurs un
projet social et solidaire un engagement
pour la transition écologique et de la
démocratie participative
j'ai fait le choix de venir participer à
la réunion aujourd'hui parce que je suis
déjà impliqué dans une dans une
association à l'échelle à l'échelle de
notre résidence et le projet
m'intéressait puisque il le reprend les
le côté le côté associatif et et vie
locale les éléments forts de réinventer
le recours sont pour moi effectivement
tout cette volonté de rechercher le
vivre ensemble le respect mutuel
l'humanisme organisé cette réunion chez
moi aujourd'hui il ya une semaine
élection était une manière effectivement
de ba de concrétiser encore plus loin ce
travail la prochaine réunion pour la
liste réinventons elancourt le jeudi 12
mars à 20h30 à la maison de quartier de
la ville dieu en présence de benoît
hamon à magny les hameaux de listes se
présentent pour ce scrutin face au maire
sortant bertrand ou lyon c'est lionel
lindemann actuellement conseiller
municipal de l'opposition qui mène
l'équipe de manille citoyens une
campagne portait avant tout sur l' envie
est de désenclaver magny les hameaux qui
l'estiment isoler les propos sont
recueillis par mélanie poké on considère
qu' on ne sait pas assez partie de notre
lien avec la communauté d'agglomération
avec paris saclay voilà donc ça c'est
l'un des axes principaux notre programme
il faut mettre en place évidemment des
navettes supplémentaires
houssin la hausse à la commune mais
aussi avec
les équipements intercommunaux et puis
fin de campagne également à montigny le
bretonneux avec la tenue des dernières
réunions des trois listes engagées
alternative ini monteyne écologique et
solidaire menée par caroline ce chaos et
vivien gasc présentera ainsi son
programme et sa liste complète mardi 10
mars à 20h30 ce sera la salle jacques
brel
parmi les principaux points défendus par
cette liste issue du travail d'un
collectif lancée l'an dernier à la
transition écologique la solidarité et
le vivre ensemble ou encore la
démocratie participative
[Musique]
on termine ce journal à plaisir les
élèves du lycée jean vilar ont accueilli
à l'écrivain hugo boris auteur du roman
en police il sera prochainement adapté
au cinéma avec omar sy et virginie efira
à la fiche il a pu raconter son parcours
aux lycéens mais aussi parler de
littérature d'autres auteurs
participeront d'ailleurs à la leçon de
littérature dans les villes de saint
germain en laye de versailles ou encore
de saint-cyr-l'ecole le reportage de
mathilde et demi au lycée jean vilar à
plaisir c'est leçon de littérature cet
après midi pour les élèves
hugo boris écrivain raconte aux lycéens
son rapport à l'écriture
son parcours personnel et donne quelques
conseils pour trouver de l'inspiration
et développer sa créativité
j'ai trouvé très intéressant le fait
l'expliquent les différentes raisons qui
l'ont poussé à écrire
et là il nous a vraiment expliquer dans
les détails et oui j'ai trouvé très je
trouvais ça très très intéressant ça m'a
beaucoup plu ces choix sur le moment qui
m'a le plus intéressé c'est l
interaction entre l'auteur et nous il
nous donnait ses procédés d'écriture ça
j'ai bien aimé parce que moi l'écriture
c'est un monde qui m'intéresse pendant
un après-midi les romans de littérature
classique sont restés dans les sacs
une rencontre qui permet de découvrir
des écrivains en dehors du programme
scolaire
moi j'ai abordé cette leçon en
me disant que c'était l'occasion de de
parler de littérature de l'intérieur
sait vraiment comment je j'élabore je
construis un livre une action proposé
par la région ile de france et par les
professeurs du lycée une fois par an un
écrivain vient parler de son actualité
aux lycéens
laurent souchon professeur de lettres à
proposer cette rencontre avec hugo boris
c'est une vraie rencontre vivante
d'abord ils rencontrent les auteurs dans
leur singularité et puis aussi découvre
le processus de création les oeuvres
sont donc portés par le contemporain
elle reflète les problèmes de notre
société
une leçon de littérature qui a redonné
envie de lire et d'écrire à de futurs
écrivains en herbe la prochaine leçon de
littérature se déroulera le 19 mars à
saint germain en laye c'est la fin de ce
journal merci de votre fidélité belle
soirée à tous sur tv 78
[Musique]